Republicans on the House Intelligence
Committee are now accused of changing a
classified memo after voting to make it
public
the four-page memo from committee
chairman Devin Nunez claims there was
inappropriate surveillance of the Trump
campaign by the FBI and the Justice
Department the committee's top Democrat
congressman Adam Schiff claims GOP
staffers secretly altered the text
before giving it to White House lawyers
Paula Reid is at FBI headquarters in
Washington Paula good morning good
morning we don't know if the president
has actually reviewed this memo yet or
which version he received now
Republicans say the changes that were
made were minor edits including some
grammatical fixes and two changes
requested by the FBI but Democrats
refute that they say the changes were
not minor and they are demanding that
this memo be withdrawn and that the
committee be allowed to revote on
whether this new altered memo should be
released
Norah Paula so detail why the Justice
Department is worried about this memo
getting out I've talked to a lot of
sources inside the FBI and the Justice
Department folks who have served
multiple administrations and it's pretty
consistent across the board they all
believe that this is part of a thinly
veiled attempt to undermine mulher by
trying to focus attention on federal
investigators and federal law
enforcement as the real scandal because
remember this memo focuses on Deputy
Attorney General
rod Rosen Stein he is overseeing the
Muller probe and he has final approval
on any charges that are brought so if
you can undermine him you ultimately
undermine the outcome of the Muller
investigation John Paula thanks